[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and it's the return of
the batch once again for the last time
in a long time as we are at the finale
of season one the ending has a lot to
unpack from it and it's filled with
easter eggs hidden details things you
missed and also some hints towards what
could be happening in the future now
last week we joined our group as they
returned to camino to rescue hunter who
had fallen into the crosshairs of cross
air he offered hunter a choice to either
join the empire or be destroyed but the
antagonist quickly learned that the
imperials aren't exactly team players
the batch returned to their home in
order to rescue hunter and they found it
completely abandoned it turned out that
this was a trap set by the empire who
rained fire on the location destroying
it in one of the most impactful scenes
of the season now shout outs to
eckhart's ladder who pointed out that it
was actually clones that were pulling
the trigger which makes this even more
messed up fear not the young padawan as
season 2 was actually announced before
that episode went live so no matter what
happens at the end of this we know that
we'll see batch streets back all right
but what does happen with that ending
well that's what we're going to be
breaking down and from here on out it's
full spoilers ahead for one last time i
need you to smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe as we're
going to be breaking down star wars
visions throughout september and october
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into episode 16 of
the bad batch
now the episode itself is called camino
lost which yeah no [ __ ] however this
symbolically carries a lot of meaning
beyond just the location to me it sounds
very much like a sports announcement for
when a certain side loses a game the
clones are all technically cameron owens
as that's where they were created and
with their home being destroyed camino
lost now we open with the siren which
was first heard so sorry that was that
was a bit of a reach uh sorry about that
now we opened with the siren which was
first heard on the death star as the
laser is powered up this noise too
appeared in the mandalorian during the
balkatan episode and it instantly grabs
your attention to let you know how much
trouble they're in the empire completely
smashed the place up like you should
smash that like button and omega azy and
crosshair are cut off from the batch
last week when hunter told crosshair
that the empire would get rid of the
clones the latter said not the ones that
matter clearly no clones mattered to the
empire though as they are of course now
in deep with project war mantle which is
completely replacing them we can see
that there are clones manning pretty
much every position on the starship
except the one that matters one actually
sounds a bit heartbroken over destroying
their home but it's clear they're all
still following their orders i think
this really comments to how people will
often go against their best interests
because someone in a position of power
tells them to and though the empire gets
all of the blame for wiping out the
clones they too had a hand in their own
destruction hunter later says that blind
allegiance makes you a pawn and we can
very much see how the empire manipulates
everyone and everything crosstail even
blames the batch at first and he would
of course only consider this if he
believed himself to be valuable next we
cut to az's eyes and this close-up was
the first time i noticed that they
actually pulled the design across from
c3po pio was of course a bumbling
nervous droid much like how az is and
it's sort of like buster it rhymes now
we learned that ac was programmed by
nola say and the cameron owens to
protect the batch at all cost and it
very much speaks to how important their
differing dna strand is they manage to
reunite and we watch as tobacco city
falls into the ocean it's very impactful
and though i thought last week's ending
was devastating this one feels even
worse under the water we catch the
tunnel from last week that the batch
travelled through and the design of this
was based on the one in empire that luke
fell through after facing off against
his father this provides a way out for
them even if it is a bit forced eh
because in star wars it's not a
coincidence or bad writing it's the
force now crosstail has a choice to
either remain behind and die or to join
his brothers conveniently their room is
still intact and here they sort of
reminisce on the past and what's come to
pass crosshair says soldiers follow
orders which was a catch phrase muttered
by the clones after their chips
activated crosses said it in episode 1
whilst arguing that they should kill saw
herrera and rekka 2 said the phrase
whilst trying to kill omega you might
also remember it as being something that
tub repeatedly said in the clone wars
his chip activated early which made the
clones in republic believe that he'd
gone crazy however he was actually
showing what was coming and it was a
nice bit of foreshadowing that's shown
up a lot of times in the saga they make
their way through the tunnels but the
cracks and the plans start to show as
the glass in it begins to split this
isn't exactly the best place to have an
argument and rekka starts saying that
they still would have taken him back
which we know is true as they're happy
to work with him now tech seemingly
defends him but he clarifies that just
because he understands that it doesn't
mean he agrees which is something that
we should definitely bear in mind when
shouting our people in the comments
section of youtube now shout out simone
birman on twitter for pointing out that
this glass cracking is very reminiscent
to the scene in the lost world and it
very much spells danger he's been part
of my crazy gang every week and a little
bit of trivia for you simon's from
norway and the bad batch is actually
called the crazy gang in norway because
of all their crazy shenanigans now the
tunnel is no longer protected and
they're attacked by a giant fish this is
one that i don't think we've encountered
before and it looks like a cross between
an opc killer a colo clawfish and the
sando aqua monster which all appeared on
abu in the phantom menace we get
confirmation of our theory last week
that omega is actually older than the
batch and though it was pretty obvious
from what they were saying it's nice
they said it out loud so we can give
ourself a pat on the back rare if that
ever happens so let's let's just forget
about all the things we got terribly
terribly wrong and move on and say that
heavy spoilers he always gets it right
the sum of a [ __ ] now we very much see
that crosshair is still indoctrinated
and he believes that he'll be part of
the empire and their grand plan this
speaks to his actions towards the end
and though i have no idea how he's going
to get off the planet he very much
thinks that he's still one of their vips
however hunter says that all he'll ever
be is a number and every time that the
empire have referred to him in the
series it's been as his cc designation
we learned that omega was very much
alone until the batch were created and
this explains why she was so enamored
with them in the first place now i
haven't mentioned this in the breakdown
so far but the face tattoos the batch
have are actually a nod to the new
zealand moko this is the traditional art
of tattooing a sacred part of the body
in order to express one's identity the
batch themselves all carry new zealand
accents due to them being clones of
jango fett who was played by tamira
morrison so this is a nice little note
to that using the cloning tubes they
flow to the surface and this has some
symbolism as they were of course created
in these and now they're being used to
save their lives however it's not all
plain sailing and az has to push the
debris out of the way as his power
supply diminishes omega gets caught and
he pushes her to the surface before
conking out if only we had a gunk droid
or something at this point we need your
gunky now his death was almost one of
the saddest in the season and he gets a
jack and titanic moment which makes
omega diving after him crosshair
actually saves the character after
making it seem like he was gonna shoot
her and he of course had orders to
destroy them if they wouldn't join the
empire so this action very much shows
that he switched sides again however he
decides not to join with the batch and
they state that though they want
different things it doesn't mean that
they have to be enemies they look over
the ocean and see the destruction and
this is one of the rare times that we've
seen kamino in the daylight it was
actually shown in the battle of kamino
like this but as i've said yeah we
hardly ever see it in this light
typically it's always shown at night
amongst the storms and this changeup
makes a nice emotional moment omega says
that he's still their brother and they
leave him to an uncertain future which
again no idea how he's going to get off
this now we cut an lsa being transported
to a cloning facility i believe that she
is being transported by delta squad who
have shown up in the clone wars before
and also republic commando the imperial
scientist that arrives is wearing very
similar clothing to what we saw the top
heads stunning in rogue one and they
tease out what's to come we theorize
that nala says expertise in cloning
would lead to creating force sensitive
ones such as snoke and of course
palpatine it's nice to see that palpats
was already putting contingency plans in
place for his defeat and potentially
next season we will see the building
blocks for that grogu was of course a
paramount target for the empire so that
they could carry out their clone
experiments and we may see things from
the other side that fills in the blanks
for the clone tank reveal in the
mandalorian i believe next season that
crosshair will try and rejoin the empire
but at this time he'll be
disenfranchised due to how they treated
him in comparison to his brothers he
might even learn of the experiments and
potentially try and warn the batch and
also the rebels i think we will get a
lot more of nala say too and that the
next entry will fill in the gaps between
this and the sequel trilogy this series
did a great job of filling the blanks in
between the prequel and original one so
that makes the most sense to me i was
actually surprised at how little things
like the wreck setup didn't pay off and
i'm guessing that we'll probably see him
next time i also imagine gregor will
show up as we know he's with sid i'm
actually looking forward to seeing a
little clone family forming anyway that
season can't come fast enough and i hope
you've enjoyed us breaking down this
episode too now as for my thoughts on
the series as a whole looking back i
can't believe how far we've come seems
like yesterday i was sitting down for
that 70 minute first episode and the
show has kept me pretty entertained week
to week i think when i go back and binge
watch it to catch up with whatever
disney have for us in the future that
will probably skip a couple of episodes
here and there that didn't really add to
the overall plot but in the end i did
enjoy it on the whole now this was
really a season that i think showed the
direction that disney should be going in
the future with star wars when they've
tried to tackle the main trilogy and
those involved in it things have been
let's say rather mixed but when they
take the unknowns i think they work
really well that's pretty much across
the board and with this and also the
mandalorian i think the best path to
travel on for the company is to just
take us on a journey with characters
that fans aren't already invested in
because yeah let's be honest no one
hates star wars more than star wars fans
following the group week to week has
allowed me to get attached to these
characters so i've come to say hello to
the newbies whilst also saying goodbye
to the prequel trilogy this felt like a
great closing of the book on that saga
and though i know the time period will
probably return the show has succeeded
in giving us a farewell to the clone
army i do wish that crosshair and the
imps had have taken a bit more of the
focus as i think the most interesting
part of the story this season was
watching the formation of the new galaxy
and how the empire enforced their rules
i also wish that we saw more things from
the clones working inside the empire
that slowly realized they were being
ousted though some of the cameron owens
did provide that however saying all that
negatively yeah it has been a fun ride
and i hope that you've enjoyed spending
16 weeks with me breaking it all down i
would of course love to hear your
thoughts on the show in the comments
below so let me know before you go go
now we are running a competition right
now and giving away three mc box sets on
the 30th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and also drop a comment
we picked the winners at random at the
end of the month and the ones from last
month are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want emails to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of what if episode 1 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the entire thing from top to
bottom and pointed out all the easter
eggs so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more without the
way thank you for linked to the video
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace